[Music]
let's go to michael in portland oregon
what's up michael
hi john thank you so much for taking my
call it's an honor to speak with you
it's an honor to talk to you my brother
what's up
um my family has fallen apart and my
life is pretty much blown up here in the
last couple of weeks and i'm trying to
get some guidance on where to go from
here
yeah let me know what's up dude i'm so
sorry what's going on
so seven years ago i met this lady at
work and we became really good friends
for about two years and she was married
to a man she had been with since she was
a teenager that she had a kid with and
they were in a really unhappy marriage
and against my better judgment i pursued
her and started to date her and three
months after we started dating we got
engaged
i went head over heels i borrowed
fifteen thousand dollars for my mother
to put a down payment on a house i moved
jessica and her son in with me and we
all lived as a family and for the first
like two years things were pretty good
quick pause quick pause quick pause
and she was still married with a kid
yep okay all right continue
so we we got pregnant and had a
miscarriage we got pregnant had another
miscarriage we did that four times
this try we finally had our son about a
year and a half two years ago and then a
few months later got pregnant again and
had a daughter so now we have three kids
and we're all living in the house
for the last year and a half or so
jessica and i have kind of grown apart
there's been like a disconnection in our
relationship and originally when i
called your show i was going to ask how
to reconnect with her
but in the pit of my stomach i always
had a feeling that something was going
on and i found out that she cheated on
me with somebody that she was working
with
and it destroyed me and
we had a blowout of course about that
and stuff and
we've decided that we're going to go to
counseling and try to make things work
but she's going to move out and get her
own place
and since we've had that blowout she
barely spends any nights at home
the disconnection is 100 times greater
than it was before
and i'm just falling apart john and i
don't know what to do
i don't know what to do i
i i screwed everything up and i don't
know what to do
so number one thanks for calling and
you're right this is a mess
okay
it's a big mess i've listened to every
episode of your show and i've never
heard somebody with a mess this bad and
i don't know how i went down this road
so far
um
you found somebody who would love you
and connection makes us do dumb things
and it gets us in over our head and so
does fantasy and a picture of this could
work and we can figure this out
and
someone that looks at us and says i love
you
it changes us right
it does yeah it does um
and so if you've listened so let me
clarify a couple things one there's been
several episodes that have never aired
and probably never will either i didn't
do a good job or some of the
conversations were really heavy and just
weren't appropriate for the show and so
you're not the you're not your situation
isn't the craziest okay
when you're when you're outlining it for
me when you watch this yeah my eyebrows
were touching my my hairline okay i was
like oh oh oh let's have another oh
we'll have another kid so yes
you've done a doozy right let's make no
mistake about it i wish i could have
impressed you in a better way john
man it's all good if you were here i'd
still buy you a beer and some nachos man
we'd hang out so
here's the thing um i'm gonna be super
honest with you and i know this is a
heavy season of your life okay
okay i really appreciate that um this is
completely full stop over
she's moved on she's done it before
and she's done it to probably her
husband or her person who's still her
husband there's probably somebody in
between you two
and
then there was you and now the same
script has played itself out again
and it's heartbroken breaking and is
grief and it is shame it is all those
things
but before you do anything else before
you go down the rabbit hole what do i do
all this
you have to sit in it for a second and
grieve
you got in over your head with somebody
who
told you something and they weren't
honest with you
and they never fully went all in on you
and for some reason there's some story
in your life that told you if i just do
the next right thing that's then
somebody will love me and then the next
person will love me
and you've been trying to do the next
right thing for a long long time
for my whole life and it's never worked
out because that's not the problem
you're trying to fix an internal hole
with an external external plug and
that's not how it works
and so before any of the healing happens
before any of you what the crap do i do
now happens
there's a sit in it and grieve the sucks
and this hurts and now we got two kids
that we brought into this
and we have a third kid that's about to
have their life erupted gets blown up
again
and i participated in this and hey
like just talking to you and for a
couple of minutes
you've known all along this wasn't right
and i'm not talking about like
like
any sort of like morality like
somebody else's wife you know what i
mean like you've known something sir
what kept you going
you're right though you're right
that's right but it's haunted you but
the love has
this this this picture around love that
you've been chasing for a long time it
kept you like i'll just go one more step
and one more step one more step tell me
about that journey man because this
didn't happen overnight
what do you mean exactly
like how do you get from man this person
at work is really she's super good
looking she's funny she laughs at my
jokes she does that when i walk in she
puts her hand on my part of my arm and
nobody touches me nobody's touched me a
long time and it's not sexual but i like
it right she does all these things
and i know there's this big thing like
oh yeah she has a husband and a family
but she says it's on the rocks and i
know that's probably not true but i
can't like i'm just gonna go down this
road like
and all sudden you wake up and you got
two kids like what tell me about that
journey man what happened
i i don't know everything just seemed to
happen so fast you know and i just i
knew it was wrong going in but i just
it felt so perfect it felt so like it
just i felt like she was my soul mate i
i just i was convinced i was just i
think the problem part of the problem
was is i was single for like 10 years
before she came along i didn't date
anybody for like 10 years i had other
rough relationships that didn't end well
and
i've been alone for a long time and i
think this like you said having somebody
give me that kind of attention that i
hadn't had in so long maybe i
misconstrued what i thought was love
wasn't really love i don't think that as
much as um
you know if if i spent a few hours with
her
she
she probably didn't love who she had
become in her other relationship and you
made her feel alive you made her feel
funny you
you smiled at her in a different way
whatever it was and i wouldn't say that
she didn't love you i wouldn't i think
that would be a false
mischaracterization that would be me
being mean i don't think that i don't
think you're crazy
i think you were so enamored by the
fantasy of the family and she's
beautiful and she chose you after all
these years of being lonely that you
were willing to sacrifice your values
you're willing to sacrifice you knew it
was going to end in ash i mean we know
that it just it just sits in the back of
our head and gnaws slowly at us and for
most of us when we are in situations
like that
we know it's going to end poorly
we try to outrun that that clawing that
fire that's burning through the back of
our brains and
it causes us to suffocate the thing that
we're trying to protect right it causes
us to hold a little too tight and we get
a little too crazy about it we get a
little too intense and then that
person's
they're on to the next right
yeah yeah that's exactly what happened
too
so here we find herself
and here imagine
like you and i are sitting on a curve
man and i'm lighting your cigarette with
you and the neighborhood behind us is on
fire right so i'm sitting here with you
here we find ourself
step one is to sit down and grieve this
it just sucks it hurts
you've been lonely for a long time and
now you're staring at it again
and now i've got these kids that are in
the house like all the time and like
it's hard to like it's hard to be a good
dad because i'm just so upset that i've
let them down yeah
you know yeah i get that deserve it it's
not their fault it's my fault and i just
like i don't know how to get past that i
just keep beating myself up because i
i've wrecked them too
i feel like i've wrecked them too and i
know i haven't they're two in one but
still i have to a point because they're
not going to have that fantasy yeah and
so
you got to put a period at the end of
that fantasy and then you have to ask
the scariest hardest question that any
of us have to ask
and you're not the only one brother you
have to get in a long line for this
question
what am i going to do next
and you have no idea i'm telling you
right now you have an opportunity to
stand up and be the greatest father
these two little ones have could have
ever known
and their mom has chosen to step out
great i'm not going to talk bad about
mom
mom's going to go do her own thing
and we were never married in the first
place and so i'm going to have to get
attorney and figure out custody stuff
and i'm going to fight like hell from my
two little kids
and
i'm gonna work real hard to make this a
stable home and to make sure we've got
stable care and i'm gonna go about my
life raising these two little ones
because i love them and for the first
time in my life
i'm gonna go talk to somebody
because i don't have an appointment
scheduled on thursday atta boy man that
see
you you've helped me so much i didn't do
anything
i run my mouth on a podcast you're the
one that looked at those two little kids
and said enough's enough's enough i
gotta i gotta be different
i got to heal
so i can do this thing differently i
really want to be a good dad john that's
all i've ever wanted my dad walked out
on us and i never had a dad and all i
told myself my whole life was like if i
ever have kids i'm never going to do
what my dad did i'm going to be there
all the time for everything and i am now
and she's gone all the time she's gone
for nights at a time and she doesn't
spend the time with them like she should
yeah so i'm never going to be like that
i'm always going to be there i'll ask
you that i want you to state it boldly
are you ever going to walk out on these
kids
absolutely not then listen to me listen
to me
you are the man who stops the forest
fire of trauma raging through your
family because of what your dad did
stops with you
is this how we would have drawn it up
that you had two kids with a married
woman no that's not how we drew it up
but here's where we are
so tomorrow starts today
i will not leave period is it going to
be tough on these kids because their
mom's going to be in and out of their
life yep i will not leave i will be here
and i will get down on all the fours and
i will learn to laugh and i don't know
how to mix formula i'ma figure it out
i don't know how
how many diapers a day i'm gonna figure
it out
it's about 15 john
yeah they're they're like machines man
they keep coming and coming and coming
now if you were and i had been friends
for 20 or 30 years and you were at my
house telling me this you know i'd be
like making fun of you i'd be all over
you i'm not doing that to you i i'm
sitting with you right now okay cause
this sucks and you know and me beating
you up is there's no reason for that
you're in it now
where i'm gonna stay on you is this
you cannot move forward chasing anymore
you got to stop and own what happened
you got to own the stories you got to
own the fact that your dad left you and
you've been chasing for somebody to look
you've been trying to solve what is
wrong with me
for a long time
is it possible that maybe there's not
something wrong with me there's a
hundred percent not something wrong with
you you've done stupid things there's
nothing wrong with you
your dad left because something was
wrong with him
not you
and my fiance is leaving because there's
something wrong with her
she's searching for something brother
that has nothing to do with you
okay she's trying to feel alive and she
has put alive
she has chosen that as a as a feeling
she's chosen that as a destination as as
in a person and the moment that she
doesn't feel alive she has chosen to not
do things in her life and her
relationships that keep her alive
and allow other people to help keep her
alive she goes to the next and you know
what she's going to find somebody else
that's going to be a shiny new toy and
then she's going to be on it the next
after that
what do i do right now because she's
still living in the house with me and i
have to face this every day
should i be trying to like push her out
of the house or
one of my friends said change the locks
and put her crap outside i'm like i'm
not doing that to the mother or my
children at the end of the day she's
always the mother of my children i'm
never going to treat her like that so i
don't know what she does
my friend my friend dave gave me this
quote and i like it
and you're it's not technically your
situation but it's close enough
the moment you
somebody files for divorce
it becomes a business transaction
with a period at the end and i treat all
of my business partners with respect i
tip well i pay on time i take care of
people and if i screw something up i say
i'm sorry so that's not a recipe to be a
jerk or to be an idiot or to be
disrespectful
but it's about it's a transaction now
and business transactions start with
hard conversations and so
next up first thing you're going to do
is you're going to call an attorney and
you're going to let them know what
happened
and that's going to be expensive and
that's just the season you're in okay
the second thing you're going to do is
you're going to tell your wife hey we i
mean your girlfriend we need to have a
conversation about future
and you tell her i know this is over now
let's call it
i would like full custody of these two
kids if that's what you want
and that's what i want
i would like full custody of these kids
i'm willing to take on the burden of
this stuff i will sign it away and or if
you will sign the pieces of paper i've
already went and met with a lawyer
and um i will not be in a relationship
where you're dating where you're married
to one
living with me and dating a third i draw
the line there and it's time for me to
have some relational boundaries because
i'm modeling what love looks like to a
two-year-old and a one-year-old
i'm modeling what love and wellness and
wholeness and relationship look like to
a two-year-old and a one-year-old and
this isn't the model i'm gonna give them
okay and by the way
you
michael are worth more than this
doesn't feel like it sometimes i know i
know i know
but you are
okay do you believe me
no
that's fine i don't lie so
you can uh i exaggerate the size of the
fish i catch usually like that's for
real but i don't lie
and you're worth more than this
okay and if you will put the work in
and heal
you'll find somebody who loves you
and those two little knuckleheads
all of you
even the weird
gnarly parts even the wonky parts even
the parts where she's like
wait what you had to what and you're
like i know i know i know
i'm as wonky as they come hey brother
trust me people invite me into their
closets for a living it's what i do
we're all wonky
but you're worth being well my brother
i'm so proud of you for making the call
moving forward it's about three things
number one you protect those kids
come hell or high water you protect
those kids number two
you reach out and you start the healing
process
period
number three you start learning in short
i mean you your runway for real short
for this you got to develop new
boundaries now
here's what i will tolerate here's what
i will not tolerate and when your
girlfriend kicks and screams and yells
and oh my gosh i can't believe you're
you're judging me after all
i was wrong
and i'm doing things differently now
starting now
and the fourth and final thing is you
got to get a couple of buddies in your
area that are going to walk alongside
you that will show up at 2 a.m when
you're pulling your hair out because you
don't know how to stop a 2 year old and
a 1 year old from crying at the same
time
somebody will come over and help you
babysit somebody that will bring chips
and queso over and help rock one kid
while you're changing the other like you
need a couple of guys
now men and women i don't care people
show up and be there for you because
you're gonna need other people in this
season of your life okay
thank you for being brave thank you for
calling tomorrow starts right
now you're worth it brother make the
call